welcome to the 23rd ever podcast episode
of the iced coffee hour with jack and
graham and
me nate o'brien so so far how much has
the podcast made us
it looks like it's been about ten
thousand three hundred
wow which is crazy yeah we got to give a
shout out by the way to that guy in the
comments
every single episode he's in the comment
section you calculate how much this
podcast makes
per hour it's been incredible we just
recently passed minimum wage
and i kid you not yeah federal minimum
wage
in america you're gonna get any more
specific
and uh and uh yeah i look forward to
your comments
every single time so that's the first
thing i do i go down the comment section
he's i know he's calculating matteo hall
i think he's counting the numbers all
right thank you
yeah thank you matteo so and thank you
for coming on this episode this is
very exciting for us um a fellow member
of the finance community
nate o'brien yeah thanks for having me
guys it's funny how this kind of just
worked out happened to be in la and it
was like oh we'll just make it happen
and uh
yeah i think it's gonna be fun it's
perfect so for those that don't know you
you make personal finance content on
youtube you teach people how to make
money
uh actually you teach people also how to
save money
recently it seems like a big pivot yeah
i would kind of view me as like
kind of like the the great value version
of graham kind of like the kind of just
like the knockoff gram
a little bit um i think we make
i think we we make pretty similar
content although i think maybe in the
past year or so
it's shifted a little bit like we've
gone a little bit separate ways like i
feel like
i've gone a little bit more into like
some lifestyle stuff talked about like
minimalism and everything and you've
gone
so a little bit more maybe like towards
current events and you've got the
podcast now you've got
graham stefan's show so yeah but um yeah
saving money
you used to talk about making money
until i got like really like a scammy
niche so i don't really talk about that
anymore i remember
that your biggest videos were how to
make passive income
yeah what was that one there's one video
of yours that has like three and a half
million views
it was um passive income how i make 7200
a month and that was yeah well so
i made it because like my channel was
really down i was like my real time's
like 10 000 views
and i had like 50 000 subscribers and i
was like all right i got to just make
the video i know it looks a little like
clickbaity but i got to make the video i
pumped it out and i just
i went from 50 000 subscribers to like
150 000 in like two months
that's crazy because when you were at 50
000 that was probably about the first
time i saw a video of yours
really so i i think i saw a video of
yours before i start or maybe it was
right during the beginning
when we started working together and
yeah i'd watched a few of your videos i
think a few did you do
you did side hustles right i did i used
to be the side i was a guy and i also
wanted to get out of that because i just
think it's so like
like i don't sell anything um so i don't
have like courses and stuff from like
side hustles buy my course and then like
you know i would like to get you into
like some type of like scheme or
something but um
yeah i was the side hustle guy for a
little bit too you know
the best side hustle is to sell people a
side hustle
so what made you want to do those videos
because you mean you were you were in
college
yeah youtube i was at i was at penn
state it was freshman year of college
and um i was just trying to make some
extra money you know because
before that i was doing like manual
labor gigs uh mowing lawns
like just selling firewood side hustles
yeah i heard like real sideless
firewood yeah yeah that was a whole uh
big big thing i had going with my
brother
but i realized like freshman year of
college that it was it was so labor
intensive
and i ended up messing up my back
because i'm like kind of tall and lanky
so
um messed up my back and i was like i
need to figure out how to make money
without using my body or like relying on
my body
and then youtube it just kind of like
when people talk about success i think
about you know
what like what it takes and stuff um and
i honestly think a lot of it's luck so
like i kind of just
was in the right place at the right time
with finance youtube it didn't really
exist right like remember it was like
because you you were there in the
beginning too where it's like you go
onto youtube and you type in anything
about finance and there's no
financing it was jeremy and jack chapel
uh i
i didn't watch jack i watched beat the
bush and uh alex becker
yeah but before that it was really then
tai lopez kind of paved the way
and then grant cardone was there dave
ramsey was there a little bit uh
patrick bet david uh those guys
yeah we're really early on too gary v a
little bit
he mostly did the the work like the
hustle content not so much finance
yeah and i think we were kind of lucky
that we sort of i don't know if you
could say stumbled into it but like we
probably both
was it like very early 2017. yeah both
saw
like okay there's a obvious a lot of
demand for like the finance content
and there's not that many people making
the content so that's why i started it
was like it's a big gap in the market is
that kind of why you started
uh i just wanted to talk about it okay
that's it i was just so
like i didn't have friends in person
that i could really be like yo guys you
see the credit card
so i was on reddit like reddit churning
just just talking to everybody about
credit cards and like this needs to be a
video like i want to talk about this and
teach other people how to do this so it
just came from
me wanting to talk about it so much and
okay i didn't have anybody in person but
why why did you want to make youtube
were you interested in personal finance
before this
oh yeah um you know everybody kind of
has their like different thing that they
just love and i think
um we're probably the same in that
aspect too is like money has always been
something that's easy to talk about like
finance
because it's numbers and i love numbers
um and that's probably why i kind of
got into finance really early like a
pretty young age i'm not a trust fund
baby so you know it's not like my
parents sent me off you know with a nice
fund um it was it was just uh numbers
were so
fun and i love counting and money just
happened to be that like i would love to
be an accountant
you know it doesn't have to be my money
i just love crunching numbers and it's
not like
high level you know like quantum physics
or something so it's
how did you learn about personal finance
like what in your life
was an event that led to you being
fascinated
ah i think there was when i was in sixth
grade or maybe it was fifth grade i
don't um
we didn't do like this project about the
stock market which in hindsight was
great
because one of those too oh you did yeah
i feel like a lot of schools didn't do
that
but we had to do a project about the
stock market and i remember kind of just
like
seeing it and being like this is really
it's just intriguing
i was kind of a weird kid so like i
didn't have a ton of friends i was just
being like a bookworm read tons of books
um
and so then eventually i was just like
you know what this is interesting went
home to my parents i was like hey what's
what's the stock market and they didn't
no offense mom she's probably watching
this but they didn't really you know
they're like i think you could like buy
and sell stuff like
you know like they they like a 401k or
something but it's kind of like they
don't really you know it's like whatever
um and so they try to explain it to me
but luckily it's like the age of the
internet so this was like
literally sixth grade i don't know it's
like 2000 late 2009
um and so then i just google it like
what is the stock
like how do you invest and then that's
how i started with that so
like really small fifty dollars one
share of senior fair stock i bought for
twelve dollars a share and it was like a
ten dollar transaction fee on e-trade so
i literally paid like a hundred percent
and then like for the next like five
years i've probably just dabbled and
just like you know here and there by
like fifty dollars with something like
like save up some
like birthday money or something yeah
and so you made videos on side hustles
with your side hustle being youtube yeah
yeah um and there weren't really any
side hustle videos out yeah
so i made a couple of those i was they
were never like my
like it was always like oh my channel's
slowing down i need to make a video
top 10 side hustle two million views
it's true
so i had to pump those out sometimes but
i think i'm pretty much away from the
side hustle stuff now yeah just because
i don't like
i don't like it's fine talking about it
but i would rather talk about
things that i just care about more yeah
it was the same way for me
i knew those passive income how much i
make every single month
those videos do so well but i just it's
hard to bring me now to do those videos
i'll do them every now and then because
people
really like them they do like them a lot
they love them but i it's hard because
it's like
you're remaking the same video with now
just updated numbers which
is interesting like i would watch other
people's videos on that i don't care if
it's the same
i just want to see the new numbers but
for me to like create a video
same thing i know i know too the the
five best side hustles jack has been
telling me to make this video forever
and i can't
i can't bring myself to dude come on you
know it's gonna do well
i know it's gonna do well i know because
there hasn't been sign hustle videos in
a while
and considering our current economy like
people are probably looking for
something i don't know
i know always looking for something
else's are the same thing
that's what what upsets me is that
people think from like
2019 to 2020 there's like some big shift
inside
wait a minute hold on no actually tell
me if you watch my side hustle videos
and i'm not trying to pat myself on the
back here
but people have said i have some crazy
ideas with my side hustles one of them
was like
start like a portobello mushroom farm
like all kinds of ones
because these are things that i used to
do like you used some worms
are you serious yeah on ebay yeah
thousands i buy mealworms oh maybe you
bought some more
tv
but like weird so that's the only way
that like if i do a side hustle video
which i don't do anymore
but if i was going to do another one it
would i'll think about it for days be
like what is the most obscure thing that
you can do
or what for comedic value no like
they're just like how is it
how is that related i'm thinking there's
some some inner city kid in new york and
you're telling him to
do a portobello mushroom farm in his
basement yeah you can use that
yes that's right you can do it in a
basement yeah unless you're doing like
shiitake mushrooms
outside with some logs or something but
yeah are you serious
yeah i was but like most of the stuff i
actually
like did when i was you practice them
wow yeah like when i was younger i was
doing like
weird just the craziest weird things you
could think of to like make money
it was like what's the weirdest yeah
what are the most viable what are the
weirdest
if it's appropriate for youtube
um yeah probably the mealworms were some
of the weirdest i mean i used to sell
um a lot of like foreign currency like
the zimbabwe banknotes and stuff oh yeah
i would buy like
hundreds at a time and then just like
basically buy wholesale
sell retail right um that was my
strategy for a lot of stuff
but um the weirdest yeah probably the
mealworms
i used to do a lot of auction flipping
like i go to like a farm auction because
you know everybody kind of like i was a
little bit of like uh i don't know if
hillbilly is the right way but like
where are you from
uh like outside philly okay yeah pretty
rural area
um yeah i used to do a lot of auction
flipping so i go to farm auctions and
like buy like
half a dozen like scythes or something
about like yeah about like 40 chicken
feeders
and i buy them in bulk and just load
them up and then flip them on craigslist
like usually like three extra money on
it and what's your average like
income like your hourly income from
doing resell
uh the auction stuff was good i mean if
it was like a saturday i'd go to a farm
auction and be like a massive estate
um and you know i could i would probably
spend on an app you know i was like 14
15. my brother just got his driver's
license so he would drive with the truck
um i'd probably spend like three or four
hundred dollars
which was like like literally i'd go all
in and just like buy buy as much as i
could
um and then probably from that three or
four hundred it'd be
probably sell total sell for like you
know close to 1500
or so wow you could like that's a good
gig oh yeah oh yeah
but like you have to know what you're
doing so like there were certain things
that i would always buy like ladders
people like if you go to an auction like
oh it's a ladder whatever but like
because that's
worth a lot of money yeah and so if
you're at a farm auction and it's just
like a bunch of farmers and people who
they're like yeah i don't really need a
ladder i already have one so you bid on
you can get it like ten dollars
and you can sell it for 200. so like and
and so
that's what i would do so there were
specific things that i knew that you
could flip and i can get really high
return on investment
that's really really nice that's
fascinating yeah and that's
that's pretty good flipping like getting
a thousand dollars and one day
and it just like it's not really it
doesn't have to be rocket science like
i'm all about like not reinventing the
wheel like sometimes people think they
need to make like a big startup and like
go
billion dollars or something but some of
this stuff's like basic like
what i suggest if people are trying to
like make money or do like this little
side hustle like auction thing
you just find something that you really
like you know a lot about it and so for
me when i was a teenager it just
happened to be like farm equipment which
is kind of weird
but um so like i knew the value of
everything at the auction
so if you can go like a pokemon like
like auction or something you know like
what the value is right
um i don't so i would never go to that
auction because i don't i don't know
what i'm doing
um so that's what i would suggest go to
something you really know the prices of
all of them
let's go back to the port about uh
portobello mushrooms how do you do that
uh i didn't i mean i wasn't so i
ventured into it i probably sunk like 40
bucks into it and i didn't
it didn't go all the way in um i just
didn't think it would be worth it
but if you're growing portabellas i
think you'd want to get like you could
stop like a trash bag with like straw or
hay
right and then you would like put the
like spores inside and then they grow
but you can grow them like your basement
and stuff
i think yeah who's frozen craigslist
being like portobello
mushrooms like restaurants and stuff and
actually how do they translate
well i don't know that's probably why
you get that far yeah
you said the trash bag of mushrooms
pennsylvania is actually the mushroom
capital of the world and i kid you not
and we pride ourselves in that and most
people don't know it but it's the
mushroom capital of the world
i used to go to the farm show out in
harrisburg and it was always just
mushroom people everywhere they're like
start a mushroom
like yeah so i just i got i was really
i was this close to starting the
mushroom farm full scale but
it just didn't go through there were
other opportunities yeah how much do
they make
the mushroom farmers i i mean you should
bring it on
next next next uh episode for the 28th
episode you should bring out a mushroom
farmer gosh
yeah and what about the the mealworms
really quickly because i had mealworm i
i still do but i tried breeding
mealworms because i'm an efficient guy
you know i'm a
economics guy right so i have a bearded
dragon her name's nora
and i was trying to breed mealworms so i
could lower my
my costs but it never worked it didn't
work i tried really hard what were you
feeding them he
turned them off that's why they saw his
face they're like nope
i'd rather die i cannot reproduce in
this environment last episode was so
positive
changing i'm kidding but yeah dude it
didn't work
uh they didn't breed i got the beetles
because they they they pupate and they
turned their little papers yeah and then
you separate them as like
oh i separated them yeah and they just
didn't do anything they just took up
space under my bed how long did you
smelled it how long did you have them
before you gave up hope because they
take a while it was a few months
oh yeah i've never had problems it's
been the easiest thing ever
you just i mean this is like 10 year old
me but doing this but like
yeah it was really easy you just
separate them you put the beetle
separate and then eventually like you
feed them you just put them in like oats
yeah eventually they move the chicken
feed it was more effective but
like water crystals and stuff like that
yeah you can hydrate them
i really don't know um i'm sorry that it
didn't work out for you
you know what i'll maybe in another life
yeah try it again maybe
maybe i'll send you some meal worms uh i
have to i got plenty
okay let me know
gosh that's fascinating dude those side
hustle videos were great
same as yours i always loved them the
one thing that always really captivated
me was becoming a typist and typing up
stuff i thought that was so
funny it does i never said that though
it wasn't you was it you no
i don't i never mentioned that once but
i swear i was watching
maybe i was down the rabbit hole of like
those kinds of videos but people were
always saying yeah i'm a typist for like
people and yeah like online services
yeah it's a shame
how downhill a lot of those videos went
and that's and that was my biggest
hesitation making any passive income
video or side hustle video anymore
there's such a saturation of side
hustles
that like you get paid 20 dollars a
minute
to watch videos online it's like how did
it's so
make 800 an hour by just clicking
buttons yeah yeah by pressing buttons
yeah
it's terrible but then you get mixed in
with that crowd inadvertently because
you're making
similar i don't know not so much anymore
like because i don't make those videos
anymore because it turns scammy so
i hope i don't get mixed in with it too
much but also i think if people watch my
videos they'll be like all right this
guy's not selling me anything
like he's not like hopefully that's
that's kind of how i view it
oh okay he seems like kind of you know
like a decent person i hope
is your only source of income youtube ad
revenue uh
no i do sponsors uh affiliates like
robin hood's
kind of like my primary so but it's all
purely based off of youtube
uh for the most part yeah now i mean
yeah for the most part
jack and i were having a bet earlier you
feel comfortable telling us how much
you're making
i i i say a number and then jack has a
number we'll tell you afterwards
if you want to we can bleep it out okay
yeah we can i
i don't really you yeah yeah you've made
videos and passive income in the past
the last time i made it it was january
or february of this year and i said this
is the last time i'm disclosing
my income because i think sometimes like
at first
it's cool it's like oh he's making seven
grand a month it's like that good for
him
and then like once it starts getting
into like the higher ranges it's like
i feel like the sentiment changes a
little bit right i guessed higher than
graham
yeah but yeah me we really underestimate
i didn't
i feel like i watched that video but i
probably just forgot january's a long
time ago now
yeah i think i haven't seen that video
i've been i was so so that video was 42
000
a month although that was including like
some stocks that i sold okay
what about just your current income no
no stocks no
just just current i was including stocks
no investment so yeah so not including
investments because i don't you know um
it obviously that fluctuates a lot um
and i i don't sell usually
um but for my personal brand
wait do you guys want to guess or decide
i'll tell you listen
i'm wrong anyway so do you want to say
it i feel like i
might be an idiot myself i'll be an
idiot i guess 25 grand a month
is what i guessed okay i guess i didn't
exactly remember the number you said in
that video i
sorry man i said 20 because i hadn't
seen you post in a while
no once a month now so i'm like it's
just residual 20.
i can pull my ad revenue for you it's um
so i'll just tell you guys it's it's
like
50 a little over 50 000 a month from ad
revenue oh oh john marriage
yeah i honestly don't even check
that's incredible my youtube studio very
awesome i feel like you just have a
really
laid-back lifestyle though 37 000 700
um let me see this yeah i i literally
don't check this app for like a week at
a time sometimes
yeah what it's it's very so my strategy
is always like what happened that day
man
that was um brand connect uh with
youtube don't
say yeah but yeah um that was cause like
if you work through brand connect like
a sponsorship through directly through
youtube so there's no like brand manager
so like i did a deal um with the company
and like they directly deposit it
like into my youtube account as a
sponsor youtube
take a cut not that no cut no no cut on
my end they probably take a cut
somewhere in there but not on my end
yeah that kind of really skews the uh i
know it messes up the
yeah all right here we go yeah wow
like i haven't posted in three weeks
maybe yeah i don't even know
um that's i gotta say i am really
impressed
because not only that but you've been
gaining subscribers a consistent amount
of subscribers by not
posting yeah you gain every day
uh what is this almost about a thousand
subscribers a day from not
posting yeah um and that's why because
of the content that i make
is i really try to make it to be
evergreen
long-term content that i know i can rank
for but also i really do think that like
i got grandfathered into this a little
bit
with the finance stuff like if you if
you go to youtube and you type in how to
save money
um or like how to invest like i'll show
up first or second
and it's just because like youtube just
they really like you either they like me
or
i just got grandfathered in somehow like
they're just like yeah let's just keep
keeping him at the top um wow i
i i'm envious of um
this is like doing better than the
second chance yeah so here we go
dude the second channel how many
subscribers do you have on this
on mine yes like almost 800 700
something
i don't know so we got something we got
500 and something on the second channel
you're growing
look at those real times yeah but look
at the income look at the income you're
making
so you're posting uh what is it one
tenth
the time what we post you've gained
what the same amount of subscribers okay
you've made
more well you made less money obviously
the one the sponsorship
yeah yeah uh yeah you got half the views
by posting one tenth of the time
uh it's just you you've ranked so well
and your top videos here
stock market for beginners yeah that is
one of my top ones
you beat uh jeremy oh yeah yeah
financial education oh shout out to
jeremy yeah
but uh i think the algorithm gave you
the number one spot
in stock market for beginners 20 20. how
to invest step by step
yeah that's my little scene that's your
that's your money maker
jeremy to that video jeremy had his like
a wild video on that he does it every
year
you beat him to it sorry jeremy my
minimalist apartment that's an evergreen
video
yeah it's six thousand views a day every
single day
like but so my channel has always been
weird for literally three years my
my growth has been so like here let's
look at my subscriber growth over a
lifetime
it has been so steady like i've never
there's never been a 60-day period where
i made less money than a previous 60-day
period ever
seriously so it's weird like it just
grows but the problem is
anytime i start seeing a lot of growth i
just get even more lazy and i just
will like stop posting until like you
know so like my subscriber growth has
always just been nice and
well it doesn't look that stupid is
there any chance you could screenshot
that yeah sure so i can show up in the
video yeah
sure like subscriber growth has been
pretty steady um like in the past
365 days like it's just been nice and
steady
wow i don't know i i think it's partial
luck it's just kind of but also like
when i
i don't know when i need to start when i
see things
things starting to slip like if my real
times go below a hundred thousand i'll
be like all right i i gotta get to work
i gotta do something so i'll make a
video how do you how do you get so
passive about that because for me
i'm like a shark when it comes to this
and if the views dip down if a video
doesn't perform well
like first of all it ruins my day and
i'm like okay what am i gonna do the
next like i gotta change it
i'm working like 12 hours a day almost
how do you how do you not see that is
like this golden opportunity that you
got right now and you're like okay i
gotta double down you gotta take things
how old are you right how old are you
right now i'm 22. feeling a little
honest with you my bones are just
right 22. i thought you were like 25 for
people think i'm instance i don't know
why but you're 22. see i see this as
like you got this golden opportunity
golden you don't know how long it's
gonna last but but you you have this on
a silver platter youtube is like here
you go
just you're a safe content creator who's
not selling anything
it's a good image who's given good like
valuable content
why wouldn't you just double down i i
feel like there's so many opportunities
in so many places that
you know i i'm working on a couple
things behind the scenes but i don't
really you know talk about that too much
um
but uh you know i i feel like i just
like
living life doing things like i think i
agree with that that's the whole summer
this whole summer i was in colorado just
up in the high rockies like just living
on government land
just in a tent like that's why i didn't
post most of the summer so
that's what i'm saying i just live in
the brand yeah there's always
opportunity
that you just like to enjoy because
things are sitting pretty for you right
now and you're just soaking it all up
which is totally fine yeah i think you
and i are fairly similar right like i i
i think at least this is how i am right
now like if i hit a certain threshold
anything above that is not it's not
going to drastically increase
my quality of life yeah right like once
you're well into the six figure range
it's like
you can kind of i don't know it doesn't
i'm not shooting for like
billions i don't think maybe um so
it's kind of like but since you've hit
that then all of a sudden like
do you do you lose motivation because
you're yes
and that's bad you know like when you
get to like a certain like say you're
doing a hundred thousand a month and
then you're just like
you definitely get comfortable so like i
don't know how that doesn't happen to
you i've never got no
what was the what was the income that
made you comfortable
oh it it's like it happens on every
level like when i was
um junior year of college just making
like four grand a month on youtube and i
was like
i felt like i was balling out because
like a college student was at penn state
um so i was like you know buying pizzas
like yeah like falling out right
um so i got kind of comfortable then and
then again when i like pretty much every
time i have a big growth spurt
i get comfortable and now it's just
getting really really comfortable
it's not good but now you stop floating
entirely and just like well that's kind
of been my plan since i was like really
young is
i was like i'm just gonna make a ton of
money for a couple years
and then just cruise like for the rest
of my life i don't need that much money
i can just live off the land
that's right yeah and and like that's my
because like you can get into like the
purpose of life and everything
um probably don't want to go down that
rabbit hole but like overall one of my
things is like just enjoy it and like my
favorite thing to do is just
sit on top of a mountain and just just
sit there
is that weird i don't know look over
everything that you could have if you
wanted it
but you could watch videos like that on
youtube no you could just watch a video
sitting over a mountain
no and and then like well as long as
you're like really happy with what
you're doing like obviously you're
enjoying all this stuff um
but sometimes you see people who are
like really not
really not enjoying it but they're just
like pushing through and they're
miserable and like maybe they're making
20 million a year and they're miserable
um i would rather make you know 100
grand a year just
be really happy so how much of that are
you saving i
i try to find expenses but i don't i
don't this sounds like
i sound like an [ __ ] i'm sorry um
that's pretty much all of it like i
don't okay i have a travel fund
um that i usually save a couple percent
of my income
so i use that for like travel and trips
and stuff i try to spend on on trips
um i i save pretty much all of it what
do you do
what's your investment portfolio look
like uh actually really quick before you
answer that this is a good point where
we could turn it off and on really quick
yeah thanks so what's your investment
portfolio look like
uh i actually did make a video about
this um one of the ones i made
was fairly well the only one i made in
the past month yeah um
was it was uh so the breakdown was like
it's like 30 it's like 34 35 percent
cash
that's my biggest problem is like well
so i know andre was just on yeah
he's talking about like how much cash he
has on hand and that's kind of a problem
too is like
geez this sounds so bad but like finding
places to put your cash like because i
don't
and the thing i don't want to do is just
like dump it all into the market
um but i do have i think it's like 30
in individual stocks so like snap was
like one of my largest positions
and today yes how much did you have in
snapchat
it's it's it's not a lot but it's it's
it's in the five figure range um why
it's like 10 grand
yeah so it could be like 10 levels it
could be 10 grand or 50 grand
can you share how much you uh it's it's
it's like i don't know
no i'm not gonna get it
i don't talk about my um i don't i never
talk about
how much money i have in individual
stocks like individually so when i broke
it down i did it in percentages um
i i just don't want people knowing that
like like
my income even is kind of weird to talk
about but like my investment portfolio i
just like to keep that
okay a little um but yeah it was one of
my larger positions
like facebook as well um paypal
penn national gaming went from like i
was so that's like
they bought barstool sports yeah so i
bought their stock
right after they bought barstool just
because i you know i thought there's a
lot of value in it
um just based off like the velocity of
their brand um
and i bought average buying was like
maybe upper 20s and then
corona virus hit and it went down to
four dollars a share and i was like well
i literally lost all my money like
28 to or 20 some to to four dollars
and now it's up like almost 70 a share
wow and uh spotify too
so yes individual stocks make up close
to 30
or so give or take of my portfolio and
then i have another like
25 and just like s p like vu right
okay cool and then on top of that
uh we got that yada yada investment yeah
yeah you can use coupon code nate graham
we'll bleep that out
bleep that out um
and then um what else do i have um just
a little bit of crypto
i don't really i don't do a lot of with
crypto um you know for some obvious
reasons
it's just i there's so much there's
there's speculating and then there's
investing it's like i'm not bashing on
crypto investors but i just don't know
enough about it to like go all in on
but you're still doing going pretty
heavily into individual stocks
yeah and i try to tone that down 30 is
not crazy though well it's
it's split up between like you know like
two dozen different companies more than
that by now so like you know it's not
it's not crazy um
and i i try to tone that down because
you have to be a little bit active about
it
um which i don't like being active about
my investments like the index fund thing
is is really
nice to just kind of set and forget um
and then what else just some some gold i
shouldn't i shouldn't
tell them where i have it uh let's just
say having a gold fund or something
where you have it it's on his wrist yeah
no it's not um
and what else i feel like i'm missing
something something really small
um bonds are like three percent or
something but nothing so it's gotta be
what at this point like one and a half
million total one million i don't know
how much i'm not i'm not a i mean no
graham it's like
you're forgetting about taxes it's
around 950
wait are we are we including taxes no
just your investment portfolio
it's got it it's got to be why what you
want to spot here
so people love coming on our podcast
they love it i'm a peach
i'm not sure if i'm gonna give you a
figure range but blur it out let's just
say that that
uncle sam takes his his cut um from all
my income so and i've only been doing
this for like
do you have an escrow two years oh yeah
okay but like i've only been doing this
for a couple years and like
you know last year i made like 200 some
thousand it wasn't like crazy and then
this year
yeah it was like it scaled up you know
like and before this like i was in
college
so yeah so like i literally had zero
dollars i'm thinking like yeah i'm
thinking like because i remember
watching your videos 2017 so i'm just
assuming like
just four years of these crazy no so i
forget yeah the last two years your
channel has really just exploded and
you've had all the success
last year at this time so right now it's
at 780 000 maybe
um and last year this time it's like
three hundred thousand yeah
and then last year before that it was
like 40 000 yeah you know so and then
just like 10 x's every year except this
year it might be slowing down a little
bit yeah
because you're not posting enough yeah
that'll
would you ever look back at this i mean
you got your entire life ahead of you
if you just stayed consistent posted
twice a week for two years
you could set yourself up in two years
for the rest of your life and you'll
never have to worry about it
because now you already can though i'm
not running a risk i'm not worried about
it because
he's still making i mean you're making
analytics yes but i'm saying there is
a chance if something happens to youtube
something happens or
you want to start a family one day you
want to you want to have the freedom to
be like you know what i want to live in
uh new york city i want to live in san
francisco and
now i got wife and kids um it costs
money so
but and you could you could fund all of
that in two years and
it just gives you options i know what
you're saying yeah but um
i'm not i'm not too worried about it
like i think there's um as long as
you're able to innovate and change and
like that's why
um i think the reason why my growth is
still going is because like i'll take a
step back and be like all right i need
to change something up
because the worst is like when you see a
youtuber who's been doing something for
10 years
and they're making the same videos yeah
for 10 years straight and they're like
getting 2 000 views per video
so i always like when i start to see the
graph just start to slide a little bit
and i'm feeling a little bit motivated i
will go in and i'll be like all right
i need to change something up and then
so like that's when i hired my
videographer
so for like a little bit more cinematic
videos um that's when i did like the
minimalist
apartment thing like when like so like
i'd say every 12 months
i look at it and say i gotta change
something up um
and so i'll probably do that you know
later this year i'd be like i gotta
change something
where are you changing too i'm going
more towards i'm actually kind of
getting out of finance
a little bit i've noticed you've taken
the matt davella
approach a little bit i just i like it
um i feel like i've already hashed out a
lot of the finance stuff
um and i kind of not not that i'm tired
about talking about it because i love
making videos but
i don't like to repeat myself on youtube
ever um because i just feel like i'm not
providing as much value as i could be um
and so the lifestyle stuff is a lot more
fulfilling
you make a lot less money on it um
because the ad rates are just way lower
but i don't really mind like i i'll
willingly make less money
and that's why like like you guys
probably know too like i don't sell
courses just because i don't really
need to make that much money maybe
that's i know that doesn't resonate with
some people but like i just don't really
it's it's for fun
yeah i do all this stuff and like also
like money's a byproduct
of whatever i do um that's just how i
work yeah
well you've taken an interesting
approach with youtube that that makes me
rethink some things
it seems like almost all of your videos
are meant to be evergreen not all of
them but like a large percentage of them
and all you need to do is rank 20 videos
on evergreen topics and as long as each
one of your videos every month is
just can get views for two years that'll
really solidify you as long as the
algorithm places your videos towards the
top
yeah and um like i have videos from 2018
uh so it's like two and a half years ago
and they've been getting 5 000 views a
day
every day you know for two and a half
years like consistently just flatline
um yeah i mean that's that's just what i
do
and i i like the views this is what i do
i make
get 5 000 views a day every single day
slow and steady nothing crazy but
it works that's cool yeah props
let's talk about financial minimalism
yeah so
explain what financial minimalism is or
just minimal first of all
i think i feel like you coined financial
minimalism i knew it okay
because so sometimes like in the the
finance
community or uh just on youtube in
general i feel like
somebody has a video that pops off and
then everybody kind of like like so like
you've had a bunch of those where you
make something yeah and then everybody's
like oh i'm gonna make a 72 dollars a
day
72 a month tesla video two um i think
the only one that i had
that a lot of people saw and were like
oh i gotta kind of ride that a little
bit which is how
youtube works you know like everybody
knows that um so like i made the
minimalist video
right the middle of this apartment yeah
it blew up and then like i did
my minimalist yeah yeah yeah um so then
you coined financial minimalism i think
and yeah oh yeah that was it yeah so you
made my minimalist house tour
and i wanted i didn't want to say
minimalist i didn't want to just say
that because then i would be copying you
so i was like
what can i say that's finance related
i'm like financial minimalist
that's going to be in a dictionary one
time one day and it's going to be graham
stefan is the founder of financial
minimal i'm happy to get credit for that
but i want people to know like i had no
like there's no real like it doesn't
mean anything i just like financially
i took two words that's the key word in
there seriously i just took two words
that sounded good no real meaning behind
it but it
minimalist i works it sounds legit it
sounds like it should be a word it was
not frugal
i'm just a financial minimalist it's
crazy without yeah that was uh
that was my financial minimalist home
tour and then after that i had a few
other videos how to be a financial
minimalist
it decently well but yeah yeah um so i i
am actually a minimalist like sometimes
people are like oh this guy just
stuffs all this crap in his closet or
something um i just filmed
my new apartment tour my minimalist
apartment tour and
i like open up the closets i'm like guys
i literally have nothing in here like
i i just don't have a lot of stuff so
what does that mean you have a house
that's just like am no furniture
no like i have a couch um i don't have a
kitchen table
i should get one of them it's mostly
because
i mean there's a lot of reasons for it
for not having you know it's because
it's because you don't care just like me
dudes don't care it's because we're 22.
yeah
and we're young men okay we don't need
decorations we don't need to
i hate decorations it needs like
anything that doesn't serve a purpose
like
like yeah no offense but it's little
it's all aesthetic
here's the thing i was the same way when
i i think about 25 for me is when i
started appreciating the little
decorations and the aesthetics
like you don't need this little but it
looks really good or this little red
rooster
thing there the little trinkets and
stuff i love trinkets it does look nice
i don't think or i would ever go out of
our way
everything has for me it has to have a
purpose so and there's two it could
it's usually one of two things it either
is really practical and useful so like a
blender right or like an instant pot
like
things that i really use a lot or has to
just really bring me a lot of
value or like joy right so like i have a
boosted board because it's fun
like just rip around philly with it and
it's fun um but if it's like
a trinket like just like a pot like pot
sitting on a shelf over there like
no i will throw it out i agree with you
100
i think we see it very evenly yeah
there's just no purpose for it
no i i don't need artwork anything or
anything i agree with you that's funny
yeah because you get it for free
you gave me like these paintings but i
haven't put them up yet they're just
closed too i can inject everything that
i have not used in like two or three
years and like jack you want because i
won't throw it away i feel so bad about
throwing anything useful away so jack
takes it
yeah shoes it's a good deal shirts hats
yeah uh a lot of a lot of stuff jack
just gets just nab
two watches oh yeah well so so with
minimalism it actually it
there's so many actual great benefits to
it like it saves a lot of money
because you don't unless you're frugal
when you're going like goodwill and
you're buying like trinkets there
but like for the most part it saves you
a lot of money so it goes
it's really it fits with my channel well
too and like my message it's like hey
you want to save money just be a
minimalist like you're going to save a
lot of money because you're not going to
be tempted to buy
random little things um but also with
minimalism it's like
you don't so the thing that i notice is
like certain
things like say you buy something it
might make you happy for a little bit
but i don't think it provides you
long-term satisfaction like say i go and
buy a lamborghini tomorrow like it's
cool
i'll love it for like a month two months
and i feel like it starts to wear off
after a while
and it doesn't it's not really providing
like that
cool factor like really fun anymore it's
just like your car you know
so that's another thing that like a lot
of things i say all right this might
make me happy for a little bit but it's
not going to be
long-term i'm not i'm not going to care
about it hmm
i forgot what i was going to say i was
going to say something honestly
i i agree with him 100 it doesn't make
sense to have a lot of stuff
and i i think i i saw this in a youtube
video or something
this could have been you but maybe it
wasn't someone said
in regards to minimalism one really good
benefit of it
is just the fact that you don't have to
make so many decisions yeah was that you
i'd have said that um but i'm sure other
people
probably matt davella i think he did
that in his t-shirt video
yeah yeah it's just like making more
decisions
every single day it just causes just
like anxiety or it can just like
stress you out because it's another
thing that you have to decide between
it's just like another battle in your
head decisions and then like losing
stuff i lose stuff all the time
my keys like when i go back to my
parents house sorry again mom but um
like i'll put my keys down somewhere or
my wallet and it'll be gone for like
hours i'll be searching through all the
couches and like trying to find it
if i set my keys down in my apartment
it's like it's one of those yeah it's
like oh it's either on the counter or
it's on the floor
and that's it like there's nowhere else
it could be so i find it like i don't
lose stuff
and it saves time and i don't have to
clean yeah yeah i rarely have to clean
stuff because there's not that much
stuff to clean where do you spend your
money
are you wasteful on anything am i
wasteful on anything um
or like some splurge you're like listen
it's gotta be food uh
not not so much i mean i don't spend a
ton on food um it's probably traveling
probably traveling because sometimes
it'll be like a weird like um
like in march i was over in europe and i
had to come back to america so i dropped
a lot of money on that ticket because it
was like mid-march and i was like you
need to get back to america by midnight
like
uh because the whole thing going on so
um traveling definitely you know
like um and that's why i love spending
money like i used to spend it in
i used to go to hostels and just live in
hostels like that because that's fun
um but now i might be kind of moving
into like the hotel
you know splurging a little bit
lifestyle inflation
it is lifestyle but um
no but i have a travel fund like it's
like a separate thing that like i have a
travel fund they're like a couple
percent
and i just you know so like that's my
travel thing but if you you say you have
a travel fun but what if you don't spend
that couple of percent do you feel
compelled to spend up to it
no because i'll just save it up for it
for a bigger trip yeah
if you really wanted to go though would
you really adhere to your budget
because you're like
i never reach it because like now it's
like i don't know the budget's like
it's like eleven thousand or twelve
thousand it's like and like i try to
drain it on trips but like it doesn't
really
try to make it i saw it i said no i love
it no it's
it's i get it i understand yeah but i
don't know do you travel alone
uh i love traveling alone really yeah i
so
i travel with friends sometimes but it's
hard to find people to travel with
because like it's usually very
spontaneous like literally i'm like the
day before
i'm just like yo i'm going somewhere and
i go on google flights
um and just see what's available and
stuff um but i love traveling alone
because it forces you to meet people
and i think that's fun like that's so
cool like when you go to a hostel and
you're over like say you go to like um i
don't know just saying like berlin or
something right or like vienna austria
and you're in a hostel and you just like
meet people and it's just like social
environment next thing you know you're
like like the dead sea in israel or
something just hanging out with like a
bunch of random people you met like a
week prior and it's just like
i had so much anxiety to do that i
couldn't do that yeah like
so so when i actually got here i got
here on monday i did not
like i literally got off the plane i was
like oh dang i i don't know where i'm
staying tonight like i need to find
like i had to book the hotel when i got
off the plane i was like all right where
are we going what are you here for
uh i i was meeting with with a couple
people um but i'm making like a really
cool
video in yosemite in like a couple weeks
um
i'm not gonna stay that long but like
planning out this week and everything so
yeah but i also i also just book flights
to la probably every six months
um just because there's always stuff to
do here yeah and there's always like
people to meet up with and stuff
um but i actually didn't even know i had
this flight because back in march
when like you know the world's burning
to the ground um i went and i bought
a bunch of tickets and i forgot about
this too but i bought a bunch of tickets
for like later in the year because i was
like oh everything's gonna be fine
and also that's when the airlines said
like oh you can just get full refund on
your flights
right and the flight prices were like 20
like you could get flights all over the
country for so cheap
so it's like a little insurance policy
so that's crazy
yeah so where else are you going um
i'm not really going anywhere else
probably right now um
i'll probably just go back to philly but
um this summer i was in colorado
you know can't really do a lot of
traveling now but so it's mostly like
kind of off the grid type of like
you know just like somewhere in the in
the wilderness somewhere that's kind of
had to shift the travel style because
before it was like oh i'm going to
foreign country like
go to the cities and just like you know
have some fun um but now it's totally
shifted like okay now what can we do
that's like you know just off like with
my car
just like off somewhere by myself um
just avoiding like mountain lions and
stuff hey you guys are welcome on my
next trip
yeah dude that's so awesome uh let's
talk about
clothing okay okay okay so go over your
outfit
and how much each article costs all
right um
so i'm really changing up today because
i usually just wear like black shirts
um this was like 19 or 20 bucks a old
navy maybe
this reminds me of this hypebeast video
oh yeah yeah yeah
once you got what you got you're like oh
yeah
this is like one of those like value
packs of like just like
10 black shirts at like walmart or
something so i don't know this shirt was
probably
a dollar two dollars um my pants
were i bought these at pacsun
two years ago for like i don't know
forty dollars fifty dollars i don't
remember
but i've worn them so much they're like
you see them oh yeah
these massive holes there's a big
there's a big hole in the uh these holes
were not here like
there were no holes in these jeans um
like two years ago and i've just worn
them so many times
but uh i'm not i'm not cheap it's just
like i don't i just don't
care you're a member of a financial
minimalist and also i hate shopping
oh yeah it's the worst thing to go to
the store and be like i gotta find
something to buy and i need this and i i
hate it like going in and buying clothes
is just
like it's not the money i don't care
about that it's a chore and it's like oh
now i gotta see if this
medium fits or if i should get the large
and it's like you know
um and then my shoes i just have white
shoes like twenty dollars a pair of
thirty dollars a pair and i go through a
pair like every four or five months just
because they get beat up
a lot yeah you need write-offs man
that's what you need
you need some good write-offs i know
time yeah
i don't like flashy stuff um
you get a black lambo sometimes well if
i do get a car it's gonna be black but
um
no i i don't like flashy stuff at all so
i try to keep things as discreet as
possible
just because i feel like i kind of got
past that like you know when i was like
17 was like oh
cool sports car like um and then i kind
of just
i don't know i feel like um i i don't
want to draw attention to myself yeah
what about
your watch and your bracelet oh this was
really cheap
um this was like 20 30 looks expensive
it does right it was uh on on amazon um
really cheap and then uh i was expecting
to say like a lot yeah affiliate link in
the description we'll find that
yeah selling these but um then the watch
was a couple dollars more
what do you mean a couple dollars marley
well why wait
what is it it's not crazy but it's grand
seiko that's that's i'm gonna guess what
eight hundred bucks for that one
yeah grandpa how much is this
but yeah they're not a little little
more yeah a little more but it wasn't
like
you know i figured it'd be nice to get a
nice watch but nothing then i'll just
look out
but it's nothing flashy like you know
but uh graham you
you gotta have your turn too i had a
timex
i had a timex i was like 30 um
and then just one day i was like i was
like all right i i gotta
spend some money somewhere like because
you know does that bring you a lot of
pleasure
oh wow wow there we go
not bad grand seiko is is that the
elegance that looks like the elegance
right
yeah i found it's 9 000
no no no no no it's it's 35 36 36 55.
yeah so nothing uh nothing crazy if you
see me on the street don't don't mug me
it's a replica um nice oh wait no i got
the wrong one 25 grand
no way no i'm kidding i'm just kidding
i'm kidding
i wouldn't i appreciate it i think
there's a certain um well that's the
thing about watches i'm going to start
getting into watches
um because i think a lot of them do kind
of hold they do value
and so like if i'm gonna buy if i'm
gonna spend money on something
i always try to make it and this is just
my brain that does this but like i
always try to make it like
something that kind of retains its value
and i tell my followers as too it's like
all right if you
because sometimes you just have the urge
and you're like all right i kind of i've
been saving a lot of money i've been
doing really well
um i want to treat myself a little bit
and then i find a way to like
buy something that also doesn't just
devalue like crazy
you gotta get yourself a ring dude yeah
yeah you gotta get yourself a ring
i don't know speaking of like i got
enough here already rings are you are
you dating
oh yeah you got to bring a tinder date
yeah man are you in jackson
no i'm not on tinder hot dude no no you
gotta explain
jack will give you so much advice all
right you got advice for this
what for tinder yeah for bumble for
dating on the map
i feel like it just takes time like i
don't i
so like i i did use them before and it
was just like i just wouldn't respond to
people
yeah because i just i was like i could
respond to this or i could go
do something else and i just never got
around to responding
so i agree it is much more fun swiping
than it is to
like right holding you like you get a
little dopamine
but no um i i like meeting people in
person or just like through friends and
stuff that's kind of like but we can't
really right now
yeah i know i know but there's also
people sliding the dms but you gotta
watch them yeah
you don't respond to this okay i don't
respond
all right all right yeah all right
graham what about you man what's the
what you got a girl no okay what's your
outfit looking like oh yeah okay so uh
we gotta do the cool style put on cool
music yeah
like like the cool beats in the
background we gotta like zoom in and out
as we're doing this
so yes we got the h m t-shirt cotton
okay six dollars okay okay uh swim
trunks and this monsters these swim
trunks
swim trunks amazon 10 bucks okay
uh socks those are free got those uh
brad oppenheim thank you for the socks
and you stole them or you got it he
so brad oppenheim sometimes will buy
like what he has a secondhand underwear
yeah like how which no no wait wait wait
they are second hand they are secondhand
but they're not worn yes so how does
that work brett
hoppenheim brett oppenheimer we're
wearing shops underwear yeah so he shops
a lot
look at this look at it let me explain
okay all right all right we'll hear you
brett oppenheim shops a lot so what will
happen is sometimes he'll order
to stuff online he'll order like nine
packs of socks like lululemon socks
but he buys the wrong size so instead of
going and returning them he just
leaves them unopened on my desk he did
this with socks
underwear pants shirts jackets like
honestly about eighty percent of my
wardrobe is from brett oppenheim
i think i think we found our title for
the episode right there yeah graham
wears second hand
but they're not used so it's not like
he's gonna wear it
yeah but seriously so that's where when
i have that prada shirt
that uh polo that's brett i have prada
jeans that i wear
that that's brett i have uh i gotta get
i gotta
friend people yeah buy those kind of
seriously um even
that white that nice white shirt i wear
is a tailored shirt
that was jason oppenheim's but that was
a taylor shirt but he just it got
tailored a little bit too small for him
but it fit me perfectly
so like i i get i am the recipient and i
wear it all the time
so that's that's awesome that's really
cool actually yeah i haven't i haven't
really good for the environment two
years yeah yeah so exactly yeah
and then you have a watch time the watch
so approximately 20 grand
so you're at total he's 20 000
yeah he's 20 25 20 00 20
probably yeah and then you you've got
like
not much not much for me this shirt was
a gift it was a birthday present
these shorts i have no idea where i got
them from to be completely honest
okay free that's all i have so
zero dollar man right yeah so what else
can we what else can we chat about
what else do you uh do you enjoy an
occasional chat about options trading
i don't do a lot of options it's more so
like i have a robinhood account
and i'll just mess around like it's very
like basically
all the free referrals and stuff i got
from robin hood um
and i'll just use that to just like you
know buy some puts and calls and stuff
but i'm not i'm not deep into that are
you guys
jack is oh dangerous every episode jack
tries to
connect to everyone to get into options
you got to man
the other the other night he's like
graham if you did options
what is it selling puts was it selling
covered calls selling cover calls on
tesla you would have made x amount this
week so we had kevin
on you know oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course
we had kevin on and i told him to sell
covered calls on tesla
okay and he did no he didn't okay and
that was about
a month ago and i did the math i think
it was yesterday and he would have made
if he did that about a hundred and
seventy thousand dollars
in one month a month if he listened to
me well what if he
but what if it didn't yeah exactly like
that's like what if like tesla just
something
then it would have been good for him on
the side of the call
selling the call but if it obviously if
it skyrocketed it would have sucks he
would have to pay tax on the gains and
also
yeah selling yeah you would have this
yeah i mean it all it keeps working
until it doesn't that's that's right i'm
saying it's 170
000 in income it's pretty incredible
because it worked but if it didn't work
you wouldn't have brought that up i've
i've seen people lose millions with
options and
probably buying though that was probably
buying or selling naked yeah
yeah yeah but it's still like i just
don't like that
oh you know what um click off because i
think we're
i gotta throw on another battery oh we
never publicly announced this
what so when i first started getting
into options trading i told graham that
i was very confident in my strategy okay
and graham said he would only something
like
being impressed if i went 20 for 20. so
out of the
out of my first 20 contracts i profited
on every single one of them
and i did
he made a total return of three percent
no i made a total return
it was okay so it was between two
brokerages on robin hood probably made
like
i don't know like 10 12 13
in a couple months and then on tasty
works it was probably like
five percent six maybe you made like one
percent on each one of these or
um nose i mean like as low as about one
percent as high i bought a put which
obviously is very risky and i made like
40 on that
nice but yeah i've i've clocked in like
about 1400
profit now wow but also if i'm including
appreciation of stock i've probably made
around two thousand dollars because
congratulations
you did 20 for 20. yeah i'm impressed
thank you yeah
so i got a course coming out next week
guys make sure you sign up we're going
to teach everyone how to do that yeah
but so there you guys go include your
plan now
yeah how about those comment chains oh
it's so bad
dude you get comments comments on
youtube and comments on instagram are
ruined
and and those that youtube and instagram
have to do something about it because
it's it's so bad
and it's getting way out of control like
if you go into the comments section on
my videos it's like
i can't delete them fast enough no i
know like spend forex mr
henderson something yeah mr anderson
i'm like i don't but people must
actually think it's real it must be
working yeah it works
they've made so many fake accounts on me
oh yes like spelling my name
en with the same profile picture
everything and they're going back and
literally this guy is responding on
people's comments and be like hey
send me a message and watch i will help
you invest with crypto and it's like ah
these poor people
and i get emails be like hey dude like
you scammed me i'm like that wasn't me
that was like graham's death in ian
they're like oh yeah it was
but like i can't it's it's insane it
bothers me a lot and i think i had like
at least a dozen fake instagram accounts
like
impersonate me and then just like
message all of my followers yeah and
people think it's real
um some people i mean most people can
probably see through because like oh
this guy's five followers
um and like two likes on a photo or
something but yeah you know hopefully
they can get that under control
um that's not the reason why i'm getting
a little bit out of finance like i hate
dealing with that stuff
and it's so like the the lifestyle stuff
is just like relaxed
nobody's gonna scam and that so yeah i
felt so bad for once someone
wrote a uh i think there's a website
called like scam artist alert or
something like scam alert i i forget
they wrote an article on me same yeah
cause they thought i was running out
yeah i felt so bad this this guy
uh and i was reading this not knowing
that like they were scammed i thought
this was someone just like trying to get
me yeah and they're like i paid graham
a thousand dollars for training for my
son to be a real estate agent
and he never got back to us and like and
i was like wait a second
he made this up because i don't do that
like and then
i realized like wait a second it's that
en someone spoke my name e n
and i felt terrible yeah they're still
doing it
and and i think i just saw in your story
today is like somebody's running ads
with your face on it yeah
somebody did that uh last month it was
andre jake's face
and it was my name running ads what the
hell are you like oh
i sent it to andre we could see if
someone uploaded that video
oh yeah yeah yeah i posted on instagram
let's see if anyone did it
no yeah that's that's it's so weird and
that happened like mr beast like it's
happening like youtube
really needs to get a hold on this maybe
they're just lazy about it or like
but like they don't have any checks to
see who's running ads like i see
like crypto like really like crypto
scams sometimes
running ads before videos it's like how
is this getting through youtube's like
system like how are they letting them
run this adwords like you send me one
bitcoin we send two back like
um i see it on my homepage on youtube
it's like elon musk feeling generous
today
giving back bitcoin to everybody send
him bitcoin to this address and it's
like has like
70 000 live views on it and they're all
like fake but it shows up
on my home screen look at this this is
all a week ago i delete them all and
they just pop up
a thousand likes yeah this one like just
all of these i thought my house resort
to sleeping in the car
jack gray and his team it's like oh what
they do is
they they write a comment and they say
wow i didn't know investing could be so
lucrative yeah yeah yeah i tell by the
first sentence they get
exactly then they get someone another
account to reply and say oh of course
investing can be really good i've had
great experience and the other person's
like
oh what are these experiences they're
like i've been talking to mr gray and mr
gray
has gotten me like seventh house this is
something exactly and then they're like
oh wow may i be able to contact you you
know what great i thought about
what's up i thought about reaching out
that could be a good video
but my fear yeah make a whole video on
it like exposing them but my fear is
that you do that and you you upset them
i wouldn't they're like yeah i know
exactly and they're like you know what
now we're gonna double down so i'd
prefer just like let's
quietly delete the comments they're
gonna post it back but at least we slow
them down a little bit
and guys and if you ever see those
comments just i don't know if they
report them just
dislike them just dislike them or just
call actually
just comment and say something like that
yeah comment on that and just say scam i
think that's important
i know the light just flickering
i forgot to pay the water bill i'm being
dead serious yeah
credit score no it's not it's not a
credit score thing it's just uh i pay a
late fee
oh man oh well make sure you guys like
the video and uh
check out the ads yeah you got to pay
for this electricity yeah and water
gosh yeah but no the comment section is
getting it's really bad
and what i don't like is the the like
bots
of botting the likes to the top and
youtube has to figure it away where
if a comic gets liked a certain amount
of times
and like i don't know through something
yeah it's gotta go it should go under
review so it doesn't get deleted it's
just
under review if a certain comment gets
like so many times yeah or
if they if they sense that like a back
and forth i don't know because
they keep changing keywords yeah but
there's so many like youtube just
i don't think they really care about it
a lot right now um and hopefully it
comes to their attention a little bit
more
it's because you know why it's just
isolated to finance content if you go to
anyone else's channels
it's rare yeah and that's just right
your niece has blown up so much
yeah in the past couple years like it
did not exist a few years ago yeah
so that's a shame what do you do in your
spare time
how much spare time do you have a lot
i do have a bit of spare time um so i i
do like i like to be really productive
when i want to be productive so like
when i'm working i turn off my phone
i get rid of distractions and like all
crank workout um
i mean my free time though i i go on
long walks um
like i i'm kind of like the force gump
walking like i just walk
like i'll i'll walk for like maybe
there's just something wrong with me i
don't know
but like i'll just slam i walk
like it'll be like it'll be like i'll
eat dinner or something be like six
o'clock anything
i feel like just going for a walk and
next time you know it's like you know
it's like 1am
i'm still walking i'm like oh i go back
that's a lot like just just
hanging out just walking like you're
just enjoying life
it's i guess that's weird but like i
just enjoy it like just i understand
i've been thinking and just like you
know i fully understand it rocks are
nice
at night i go for a lot of night walks
and i'll just go out and
i'll be out for a solid like 90 minutes
maybe two hours just by myself walking
it's weird jack comes back with a whole
bunch of cash on them and yeah like a
bunch of cats and scratches all over my
body
mask yeah no i agree with you i think
walks are really nice
and maybe this is another matt deville
thing but someone said if you go for
walks then the forward movement when
you're walking
actually spurs like better brain thought
or something like that like your brain
is able to work
better when you're when you have forward
movement or something like that
when i when i do a lot of thinking i i
have to be moving yeah so like i'm
people actually probably think i'm like
a lunatic because like i'm walking
through philly and i'm like talking to
myself
like i'm like yes this is like
if i look so bad when i'm thinking about
this but like that's just what i do like
if i have
or like sometimes when you're just like
doing something you just have like an
epiphany and you just
like you're out in public and you're
like yes this is it right like you you
just
it all comes together like this is the
next big video idea or something like
do you just like internalize all that or
you're like out there like high five and
people like let's go
like i internalize it oh okay yeah i i
kind of
don't interest high five strangers i've
done it before when you get really
excited about something
yeah what excited you that much i don't
even remember it's just like little
things like
well i shouldn't say little things but
just like a big like epiphany you're
just like this is going to work
so well um like video ideas um
i don't know just snapchat going up 33
yeah like that kind of stuff where it's
like something really big happens and
you're just like dang i
i need to just like yeah celebrate a
little bit
but that's cool i guess that's weird no
i respect that that's awesome i like
interacting with strangers like
um i'm i'm an introvert but like it's
still
i'm definitely an introvert but it's
still kind of fun just like meeting
people
not that i just like walk up to random
people and like high five well okay i do
i do sometimes but like i don't just
like walk up to random people and start
like creeping them out and talking to
them like it's more so just like
i think you understand like you know
social i hope so yeah
yeah how do you make friends with them
what do you do with stranger changes
i tell them what you do no no i never
tell people what i do
do you want to role play oh my god yeah
graham wants to role play with you
okay so if i'm a total stranger we're at
uh
a coffee shop or something we're sitting
at the the table i mean so it depends
like
did i just hear some really good news
you heard some really bad news
oh well bad news no i'm not gonna
actually yeah but you'd have to bleep
all this out
so i couldn't i couldn't you heard some
you're some great fantastic
yeah if i heard great news like i
probably wouldn't you wouldn't really
understand the context if you more self
i'll just be like
yeah let's go and then be like let's go
and just like high five and then i'd
like leave with my coffee or something
but you're not making friends with them
no no not not all of them yeah
most of them not actually people
yeah like when somebody's okay you can't
do any of this anymore because like
but like when somebody's running by or
if you're running if you're both going
on runs you're running past
you like give a high five like let's go
you know kind of like uh it's friendly
yeah i've never given people high fives
when i run but there's definitely like a
running etiquette where if you see
someone else that's running you give
them a nod
yeah knowledge that they're out and
they're running and you're like nice job
yeah exactly yeah like i'm not gonna
high-five everybody but like
it's like the number one super spreader
thing to do in 2020 so i don't do that
but um
in 2020 but so that's a pastime of mine
nice that's pretty awesome you're
spreading positivity i think that there
is
a very very very slim if any chance
that you doing that to someone random in
public will actually negatively impact
their day like there's no
they're probably gonna be like oh yeah
like yeah trying to reciprocate here
it's not like i'm saying something like
i don't even like compliment people
because even that could be taken
like in the wrong context like it's not
like a you know what i mean like i'm not
cat calling people
are you being sarcastic no no they had a
nice smile you're making fun of me well
no cause like people don't i don't know
people don't like i
like i don't think yeah okay
imagine going up i don't see okay i
don't think they really like your
hairstyle they're like
what did you just say to me oh no no no
yeah but some people happens a lot and
it does get like i i know people who are
like if you're like if you compliment
people i don't know
i don't know where i'm going with this
no that makes sense right like like if
you're walking on the street and like
so you're like really attractive and
walking on screen like everybody's like
hey you look great today like eventually
gets kind of uh
i don't know compliments are weird like
yeah i i personally
i'm not i do not really like being
complimented i think
it feels weird it really feels weird how
do you respond to it too
exactly it's like if i say thank you
that means i kind of like acknowledge it
and maybe it will come off as like i'm
in agreement
with it and you're overthinking it no i
i know what you're saying
as well yeah yeah now to say oh wow
thanks
really appreciate it that's something
like that easy yeah like if you're
walking
like on the street or something you see
someone's got like these really cool
like overalls or something like
like without like stopping them and
trying to talk to me like yo sick
overalls and then just like keep walking
like you don't even stop you know what i
mean like if it's actually really cool
they look you in the eye they're like i
know
that's why i wore them today no but like
like i always get caught up in this game
if someone compliments me
i feel like i have to compliment them
back you gotta think fast too exactly
nice no but that's what you say every
time yeah but like that's why like if
it's like
i know i really don't i don't cat call
people
it's not like i'm just like out there
and it's like tackling you're the only
street you're that i've got
my gt that goes around the guys this is
all very rare occurrence i don't even
know how we ended up in this rabbit hole
of like
i think we're talking about going on
walks or something like what you do in
your free time yeah i'm like digging
myself into a whole like sounding
lunatic out on the streets just like
high-fiving people
complimenting oh my god yeah
so anyway what do you do in your spare
time besides
that i mean so let's see what did i do
today
um i woke up wake up pretty early you
know i mean
out here too like uh 5 30.
um that's pretty early well you so this
summer is made up of like
6 30 or 7. um now it's because i'm i'm
came from philly so i'm waking up you
know just naturally waking up earlier
um and then yeah i just i went for a
long walk
how long yeah i don't know like um
uh i i didn't track him but maybe like
an hour
like i was just just on the beach and
then um i sat on the beach for a couple
hours just thinking
most of my day consists of thinking what
do you think about yeah
just the next moves enjoying life
um i'm a simple person really i think
that's the way to put it um
but just like the next move to make um
sometimes i think i overthink like i
think too much
and it actually could be a problem
that's one of the reasons why i don't
get out that many videos
like it might sound like i'm kind of
just lazy but it's also because i
theorized too much um and like i kind of
was like all right well i could make
this video
and i'll think for a week about it like
what video should i make next and i'll
think for weeks
you got to do some time cost analysis i
know how long you've been thinking about
that you could have done that video
and moved on to something else maybe
that's why you're a minimalist
because you think so much and if you had
all these decisions and all these things
cluttered around
it could clutter your brain it is true
yeah yeah that is true
um but what do i do my free time that is
a really good question
i spent a lot of time with with with
family um friends
you know can't do that a lot i see her
anyway but um a lot of time with family
you know
so like i'm in philly so my family's
like an hour outside philly
so i can just go hang out with them all
the time um
you know grandparents just yeah in
philly
you live alone like yeah yeah and do you
have friends
yeah yeah yeah i have friends what is
your family
what are you trying to say area and like
in the area yeah
yeah yeah because so um i i mean i'm
born and raised in pennsylvania so
i have my hometown friends i have a lot
of friends out at penn state because i
went there for like two and a half years
so there's still a lot of them are still
there and then i have a lot of friends
in pittsburgh
because they all all the pittsburgh
people went to penn state so like yeah
all over pennsylvania
but i love being in philly because it's
good location like new york's an hour
away
by train i can get to dc in two hours
like it's just perfect location i can
beat the beach jersey shore in an hour
so a lot of people around yeah what do
your parents think of all this
your youtube success at first they were
concerned because um actually i didn't
tell anybody about my youtube channel
until
they found it um i think i like 10 000
subscribers
i did not tell my friends i tell my
family right because it was like i
didn't want people to know
even now i still don't even like there's
a lot of people who don't know about the
channel
um but so my parents were like
i was always threatening to drop out of
college it's not like they really had
skin in the game because i was like
paying my for myself and stuff so i
didn't really like i didn't really
worry about that but um they were
concerned when i'd be like i think i'm
gonna drop out of college next month and
they're like no
please don't like because you know every
parent wants like security for their
child right like they want their child
to like
take the nice comfortable route that
like is the most
likely to succeed right um so they're
concerned about it and i think
eventually they just kind of started
seeing the the paychecks rolling in
although i never showed them but they
just kind of assumed i guess
or my siblings told them or something
and then so yeah they're they're
supportive of it now
yeah what were you studying in college
uh marketing yeah
so that was not not to say that i'm
against the school system because i do
think college is
worth it like when you run the numbers
it is still worth it to go to college
even if you're dropping 100 grand on it
as long as you're going for like the
right degree and stuff um but yeah i
went from marketing and it just kind of
got to the point where it's like i was
making like 15 grand a month
in the spring of 2019 and
i was like i had like all these
marketing classes and it was just it
just didn't i was looking i was like
this is not
like i'm not learning anything it's i'm
not you know
so i'm gonna drop out yeah what are they
teaching you in marketing
and just you know like managing
marketing and then like like um
well to be honest i didn't pay a lot of
attention okay
but like i like uh i think i probably
took um because the first year was all
gen eds
second year it's like a couple marketing
classes here and there i did the bare
minimum
um so you know i took like a handful
like 400 level marketing classes i don't
even know
it's like market research i think was
one of them um
i genuinely just don't even remember
because i didn't pay attention at all
but they they weren't it was it was like
it was good stuff to theorize about but
it wasn't
like i was i looked at i said i might as
well just spend more effort on something
that
i i could make money off of and also i
feel like we've learned so much
about marketing with youtube like with
organic growth
um that i think that's valuable in
itself yeah you could like
you could probably charge you know
thousands and thousands of dollars for
like a quick
youtube consulting call right and and so
i think we kind of learned marketing our
own way and what about you said that you
don't tell people that you're a youtuber
so what do you do
like what do you what do you tell them
that you do whatever i'm feeling like at
the moment architecture real estate
i think i got this from ferris maybe um
uh
if you read the four hour work week i i
think he said that like if i'm in an
uber right
yeah or like drug dealer or something
like like if i'm in like an uber i'm
going back to my place
i don't i don't like telling like uber
drivers like what i'm you know it's like
oh what do you do i'm like oh i'm a
youtuber and then they go and see make
like 50 grand a month or something and
then they drop me off in my house like i
don't want that kind of i made that i
made that mistake oh yeah i'm telling
you telling them
uh we got so sketched out um we were we
stayed in a really bad part of town
when it was me and kevin we were
traveling oh really and i booked like
the cheapest airbnb
just not thinking i was just like this
one's kind of like detroit what was this
oh in detroit i didn't realize the
neighborhoods and i just picked an
airbnb
that uh that was like the cheapest one
oh just thinking
and and kev oh even the uh so we had one
uber driver
yeah this was it so we had one uber
driver take us to our airbnb
and this guy was so cool and he was like
are you sure you're going to the right
location
we're like yeah this is it he's like you
sure like you know where you're going
and
he's like do you know people there i'm
like it's an airbnb because oh i was
kind of surprised because usually people
don't stay in that area oh no
that's the worst thing to hear when
you're getting dropped he was warning us
yeah and we're like is it safe he's like
listen as as long as he stands you'll be
fine but don't go like walking around
and we're like how bad could it be so we
show up at this place and
it's at night so anyway we we're hungry
so we get another
uber to uh to take us to a place to eat
it's down the street and we're gonna
come right back so anyway the guys seem
really nice in the car
so i'm chatting away telling him like
what we do
and i'm like we're here to look at real
estate he's like oh yeah what price
range i'm like
i'm just talking away telling him
everything he's like oh you make youtube
videos like
yeah we're here to make videos and he
was really he seemed nice he was really
interested
but it just he started asking some
questions that
then kevin raised the concern that like
listen he now knows where we stay how
many people
there are in the place when we're not
going to be there uh
like he could he could find us online
see exactly like
what and um then what ended up happening
was like an
hour and a half later as we got back
there was a car that just parked out
front of the place
just waiting oh and there was it was
someone in the car
like two o'clock in the morning with his
lights off but the car was running oh
no and kevin was just sitting there in
the window looking at this car be like
dude we gotta go
we gotta go i'm like it's not that bad i
can picture kevin
and then the car drives off and then
comes back again in the same location
and so we're like maybe he's trying to
like let's see scope it out
so anyway we i ended up posting on
instagram and being like hey if anyone's
in the area can you come pick us up
and we booked a hotel but uh yeah we got
a subscriber to actually come and pick
us up
and he we actually became friends after
that he toured us around the whole area
the next day
that's really really really cool but uh
yeah
so yeah you can rely on subscribers for
things sometimes i like i mean it's
great like
whenever i travel somewhere i i'll you
know if i just like post a story i'm
somewhere like i'll get tips from people
like yeah avoid this spot go to this
spot like go to this restaurant and it's
great like i feel like most subscribers
are genuine
like you know just want to help you out
i had so much fun i went to
uh canada and uh for a real estate
conference
and i had a flight that went to toronto
but there was no flight later to go to
london ontario
so and that's about a two-hour drive
yeah so i posted on instagram and i said
hey if anyone's willing to pick me up in
toronto and drive me to london ontario
we could just hang out yeah and within
15
minutes i had someone say no problem see
at the airport
wow he picked me up the airport at like
six o'clock in the morning drove me two
hours to london ontario
we hung out i got him uh the vip tickets
to the real estate conference he was
there
like you know how some people will just
be like i'll be there and then he'll
show up he was there the entire thing i
got him into all like the
the events we hung out we became friends
really cool
and that's just from posting on
instagram yeah yeah i've
you know you have to be careful like you
can have to vet them like oh yeah
all right like is this person crazy or
you could you could but you can tell
you could tell really quickly yeah um
but yeah you meet some cool people for
sure
yeah uh even just the other day we had
um
uh a subscriber come pick up my couch i
was upset about that
i'm still i'm still upset about it he
got a good deal on that couch it's it's
it's online right now for thirty one
hundred dollars wow
he paid under two grand for it so he got
a door
what was it yeah it was one and a half
inches too big
and they could not maneuver it around in
such a way to get it through
the door i was so upset because it was
six months
wait for that couch yeah it was so nice
and it's i'm not surprised that it was a
six month wait because when i had to
furnish my place i realized that i think
like
ikea and all these couch are like these
furniture companies just assumed that
like
whoever's in charge of their supply
chain back in march it's like yeah half
of our customer base is going to die off
yep and nobody's going to move
and construction is going to stop for a
year or something so they just cut all
production
or something and there's like a lumber
shortage there's like there's so many
like being a supply chain person this
year must be a total mess right
because it's like all over the place but
i bought a lot of stuff too
around uh march april because every
place went on sale this is the very
beginning of everything and i'm like oh
and that's when i locked in that couch
wow took six months like six months and
then it's just like
man i thought oh well i'm still sad
about that couch
it was nice jack wasn't it it was it was
nice it was a really nice couch it was a
couch
and now it's gonna go in the vegas place
no uh macy's got a
room for filming and stuff like that so
i wanted to put it in that room
and then it's just it's it's nice it
sounds like you're really
really distraught i really really like
the couch yeah
because that's because that is honestly
one of the best bedrooms
because i got my room for filming we got
the master bedroom and then we got
this bonus room here and that gets the
best light throughout the entire day
so it's like that couch would be so
perfect in there and we're gonna put
plants around it make it look all nice
so i was looking forward to that
oh well what kind of goals do you have
for the future
what do you look forward to um so my
goals are
you know uh i think every phase of life
is i
kind of i can't plan out my life but um
for the next couple years i just want to
get to a couple more million
dollars like eventually i'm not like
racing to it but like i'll get to it
and then from there i'm just gonna buy a
huge piece of property
and um live off the land what
that's my life what's that what's the
goal how many millions
ah i mean uh i i don't have a set goal
right now
i used to have set goals for like income
um i didn't set one for 2020 and maybe
that's why i haven't posted as much
um because the money i just don't feel
like matters that much
really as much but like i'm gonna get to
it like probably five million or so i'm
gonna look up this goal i have not
looked at this by the way so i made i i
think i made this on new year's day
chart what age no no no no no i made on
new year's day every single year i make
my
uh goals like resolutions that i want to
hit i don't look at it for the rest of
the year i just i look at it one day
wow i'm tempted to look at it right now
do it live on the podcast let me see
okay i'm not going to show you all of
them
but uh you'll show me years most
did i
maybe i didn't do one this year i always
do one hold on
sorry yeah you got to sign them before
new year's i usually set mine like
december 1st so i have some time to like
you do get a head start yeah because if
you sit on on january 1st
so and these this is a reach for me by
the way so when i write this out i'm
like this is a reach
yeah one of my goals is make three
million dollars okay so a year
in one year definitely did that get that
um buy another rental property
didn't really i didn't do that i put
three million subscribers by december
31st so i'm not
i'm like but these are like reaches like
this is something i shoot for the stars
i don't think i'm gonna hit this
uh 500 000 followers on instagram my big
one was uh
set up a reef tank i've not done that
yet but i got the but the drum set was
in this
start playing drums again i did that
what else is there um i don't want to go
over them
but yeah i uh i did a net worth goals
probably in like february maybe january
and i did not expect to be dropping out
of college to be working full-time
oh you dropped out yeah yeah oh wow i
must have missed that was that like a
that was a podcast okay because i knew
you were in college right yeah yeah
yeah it was probably the right move like
i think it's only good to drop out if
you
have something that's like going for you
like like you can cost like exactly
yes both college exactly this yeah and
people act like it's the end of the
world if you drop out it's like you're
done
but you just go back if you had to but
you're not gonna have to no
no we we gotta keep this going man yeah
every year
yeah every year is going to be better
than the last it's crazy expanding right
because i think it's just this evolution
that where you start off we're going to
continue expanding it's it's going to be
like the dr phil
show at some point so seriously i have a
little
i i just have a an idea in my head of
what i want yeah i mean you could
totally do it because i think you are
kind of the
the face of the finance like community
right now
and um people don't realize this but
like dave ramsey
um he's like his company is making
hundreds of millions of dollars
in revenue per year people don't realize
that like they think he's just like this
old guy
like with a microphone just like in his
basement or something like an assistant
like he has a massive
office building hundreds of people
hundreds of employees um
and honestly like i don't want to bash
on dave here and create some controversy
but like
you know like there's a lot there's a
lot more people who i think resonate
with you
like millennials for example can
resonate with you sometimes
yeah little bit more than dave just like
based off like age and like yeah you
know
dave goes for a different demographic
though yeah that is true
he's cornered his market better than
anyone else and he makes
he's basically a matchmaker so he's got
these affiliate networks where if you
want a plumber you want a contractor
you go through his pre-approved list and
he gets a kickback from that you want uh
a real estate agent he's got his
pre-approved vetted list do you want a
financial advisor and then he's got his
line
to become one of those people right you
pay to become one of the people i don't
know the exact requirements
yeah like yes i don't think he's not a
setting stone we're just
realizing theorizing theorizing
allegedly yes theorizing
allegedly that i believe my
understanding i could be wrong
is his biggest source of revenue it is
which is very smart
you're gonna get a rental property uh i
do have to get into real estate soon
um i don't have any properties um
partially because
and i think andre also kind of had this
problem with like the income
you know when you're buying a property
they want to see multiple years of
income if you're self-employed
so i'm waiting i'm going to file 2020
taxes
and then buy a property next year it's
kind of for yourself or as a rental
if i can find like a duplex it'd be nice
i feel like house hacking is kind of the
way like i know you've done that
ryan did that i almost feel like for you
i wouldn't advise you to do real estate
i think you're such a free spirit
minimalist who enjoys traveling and
not having a lot of responsibility and
overhead
i don't think you need a rental property
man okay i'll be completely honest with
you i think it's gonna i think it's
gonna probably tie you down
more than you would like and i don't
want to be tied down no yeah that is
true and that's probably another reason
why
i'm like taking my time with it so maybe
i just won't do real estate at all i
think for you the less
interaction you have and just the more
freedom you get
it's going to be better for you i think
for people who really want to like build
their wealth put in the work and get the
maximum return spot
then then i'd recommend it if you were
just like i want to just do everything i
can now for five years and then try to
retire
but if you're traveling all the time and
you just like turning your phone off for
hours on end
and just sit at the beach and relax the
last thing you need is a property
manager saying hey
uh so your foundation has a crack we
need to repair it are you gonna be okay
with this thing
all right now it's empty for a little
bit what do you want to do can you it's
just
yeah it's another thing to worry about i
think ryan scribner
was talking to me about that with his
properties like like he said like
he's glad that he bought it but um and i
don't want to put words in his mouth but
like
with the time that like he like you know
just the little things
and like what he's billable at for his
rate is like it's not really worth it
like when he
even if he has to spend 30 hours a year
thinking about the property
and if you know say you make 5 000
on a property or something over the span
of a year but you spend 30 hours on it
like the hourly rate is not worth
the time right so you kind of go big or
yeah or something
yeah for me i loved it because i had uh
while working as a real estate agent i
had like just free time throughout the
day so for me it was like it made sense
i'm gonna spend a lot of time doing this
and i enjoyed it but then as your time
becomes more valuable
i don't want to deal with it as much
anymore just because it's just not worth
it and i sometimes think we got to call
samsung tomorrow
sorry i did i was supposed to text you
earlier about this this is how stupid it
is okay
uh i bought a brand new dishwasher for
the rental property
and it was like 500 bucks and the
front seal of the dishwasher is peeling
back
oh yeah brand new yeah exactly so uh
jack was on the phone
how long were you on hold with him oh
that's such a pain like
probably like an hour so an hour an hour
and a half so an hour and a half for
this peeling thing in the front
the technician goes out and says it's
not covered under warranty
because it's not um uh it's it's it's
not damaging the actual like it's just
it's just what do you call it like
surface level it's just cosmetic it's
just cosmetic
it's not covered under warranty i swear
so and it's brand new it shouldn't the
whole thing is peeling in the front
wow but oh and also because it's not
throwing an error code there's nothing
you could do about it
so we got to call samsung again and i'm
thinking like
one hour of like my time for a
consulting call would pay for that three
times over so why am i like
dealing with the samsung repair i mean i
shouldn't be dealing with
a property manager because it's like
this comes up every night like rarely
and i look at the cause of the property
management
it does i know but like i've done it's
it's just like everything runs so
automatic but then there's these little
things that come up like that it's just
like it's
one thing i have to deal with yeah i
hear you on that for sure
so probably yeah
i mean is there anything that you wanted
to ask or talk about uh
i don't think so what's on your mind
what's on my mind uh not much right now
just enjoying the the podcast here yeah
any questions for me that i can answer
uh yeah i could do for you yeah i mean
so you you kind of already said kind of
what's next for you
uh what could you do for me um yeah what
can i do for you honestly i don't know
uh
i'm not gonna think on the spot like
this i'm sure i could sit and go for
another walk and come back
in a few hours yeah you could only shoot
me a tent like anything you need
obviously but yeah i don't like to
bother you because i know that like
no like you you probably know what i'm
saying where it's like you get you
probably get a lot of messages now and
it's hard to keep up isn't it hard it
is yeah and so like if i have a thought
i'm like oh i should ask graham this i
don't because
i know how busy you are trust me because
i know that like you know what i mean
because
like no no i get what you're saying but
the thing is with me
if uh if if you shoot me a text with an
idea sometimes it gets me thinking like
um we have group texts for going over
titles and thumbnails
and so all like i love doing that like i
always
open titles and thumbnails because i
like to go back and forth and helps me
out too and like we all benefit from it
yeah and i do the same thing i shoot out
titles and thumbnails which one do you
like
so anything you need okay yeah yeah
cause it gets all of us thinking we
could all uh because i'm sure there's
gonna be points where i'll i'll ask you
a question i'll be like hey man i don't
know what to do on this
yeah and it's gonna be not like these
youtuber groups like i'm in a bunch of
these where it's like
a bunch of you know youtubers with like
a million subscribers each and like
somehow i got put into them
and you yeah you throw in your thumbnail
you throw in your titles like hey is
this good what do you think i should do
and you get some really good insight
from that yeah
so and there's some people too that
really know titles and thumbnails and
others i just know not to ask you
because it's just it's bad yeah but
but i guess that's why you don't ask me
yeah you really got to know people who
know the finance niche too
because i've i've asked titles and
thumbnail questions to people who don't
know the finance niche but they're
really good at other niches and it's
like that
would not work for me at all so like
finance has its own little
section that works for finance other
content for other content so
yeah you can't think of anything it's
not really
i can't really think about it you have
your life all figured out yeah
i i kind of like to think that i do but
hey this is how it's going now and um
you know maybe next year it won't be
figured out but we'll have you back on
in a year i think that would be
yeah let's do it one year later one year
make some predictions
okay put it out put it out in the
universe year later i think i started
growing out the beard we're coming up on
november
i hate having to shave every day it's
like terrible um
yeah i'll grow out the beard grow out
the hair
like this just i just won't get haircut
until next year this time are you
serious
what is that like what is that into the
into the wilderness
into the wild into the wild yeah oh yeah
do that do that i think i'm just going
to go off the grid
like just because like i'm going to go
like i'm going to disappear i'm going to
stop uploading videos
i think i'll hit a million subscribers
yeah and then just go like completely
ghost
like for years like a decade oh my gosh
what and just like make a comeback
one day that's okay well it's
that's fine what's going to happen i'm
just predicting it's like yeah but i
want to hit a million i also don't
really want to
i don't want to be like a big brand um
because it gets weird like even now like
i get stopped on the street sometimes
and like that probably happens to you
all the time but for me it's usually
like
maybe once a day or once every a couple
of days um but sometimes it's weird like
i'm
walking on the street and like someone's
yelling at me and i'm like what what's
going on here and they're like i love
your stuff that's so nice man
yeah but it's crazy i really appreciate
it last week i was sitting next to a guy
on a train
and i get a message like i had this
weird feeling it's like i should check
my instagram message request because
i had some free time so i look at it and
like the message i was like hey are you
on the septa train right now
and i'm reading the message i respond
like yeah are you
and i like the guy next to me gets a
notification pulls out his phone
and we both look at each other and we're
just like and we start talking but like
it's just creepy
like i don't want to be i could not
imagine what it's like to be like say
like leonardo dicaprio or something
where you can't even walk down to
you know del taco and get some food like
you can i i don't know
everyone that comes up to me is like
really into personal finance they're
into real estate we have the same
interests
i like i don't mind it at all because if
anything it's like you you get to see
the real world impact that
that you have on people yeah and the
result
of just like everything you put out
there you could see how helpful it could
be
so that's what i like to because you
don't see that all the time when you see
the the
views and likes and comments but to see
a person be like dude
my credit score is like 800 now i've i'm
saving like 25
of my income i just bought a dude like i
went to bank of america to deposit
no to grab some cash and the teller was
like
dude i bought a duplex oh my god in
riverside
yeah in riverside because of your house
hacking video and i'm house-sacking it
and so to see that like wow you could
actually make an impact on like people's
lives like this is real stuff it's
incredible like you don't get that
unless you meet people i i agree with
that i would rather
not be the face of it and still be able
to do that with a brand or something
um you know like just if you owned say
like like if you look like the barstool
sports model you like own a lot of
podcasts and stuff so like you're behind
it
like for example if not that i would
ever run for public like like
in in politics but i would much rather
be the campaign manager
than the actual candidate and i didn't
realize that until i started growing
my brand fair enough that camera it's
probably a cue that we got to wrap up
yeah well that's fascinating thank you
so very much for coming on yeah thank
you guys thanks for having me this was
fun
i hope you had a good time oh yeah of
course okay i'm sorry i didn't drink
your coffee um
that's fine at any time past noon i
can't drink coffee i gave you coffee the
last time
that we did it collaboratively i think
you did yeah yeah
so what did you think tell the viewers
what do you think of my coffee it's good
um i i i think you should start a coffee
brand
maybe in the works if you guys hit the
like button yeah comment down below and
say graham
start a coffee brand if we get
three people saying i should start a
coffee brand i'll start a coffee brand
three just just takes three people and
then just every every podcast here is
just you're just pushing your coffee
i'll start it i i think you should start
a coffee brand yeah okay so that's one
so if you get two more people
i think you should start a coffee break
all right so one more person as well
i need to start the brand yeah there you
go starting at coffee brand
all right it's in the worst i think i i
think that's that's the next step i
would like to do that still thank you so
much for coming on it was
amazing meeting you because i i have
seen plenty of your videos before so
it's really nice to meet you in person
and uh thanks again for coming on thank
everyone here for uh
thank you guys and watching to the end
yeah
and uh so with that said you guys thank
you so much for watching i really
appreciate it as always we'll link our
instagrams down below in the description
uh get your now three free stocks oh my
god they just keep adding yeah yeah
but they did they didn't they didn't so
the two free stocks was they were worth
it minimum eight dollars
now they're giving three free stocks
with no real minimum
what but uh so it could be anything else
so that's the thing it's like
it it's a worse offer but it sounds bad
it sounds way better yeah
because getting two free stocks worth at
minimum eight dollars at sixteen bucks
but they could give you three stocks
worth three dollars each or twelve but
you get three of them
it is i think i would i think
psychologically people would rather get
three free of something than two that
are guaranteed to be worth a little bit
more because there's more chance that
one of them is going to be potentially a
big one yeah exactly
and i had someone actually reach out
they got like an 800 stock i forget what
it was
on weeble or no no it was a google they
got a google stock
wow yeah that's crazy someone got a
google stock i'd like my
the the biggest stock i've got so far
was um
alibaba and it was like 200 000 but so
anyway if you want the free stocks down
below in the description
we got the mentorship group down there
too we meet twice a week every uh
sunday and every thursday if you guys
want to talk today
and jack this tuesday if you want to
talk hang out with us uh
yeah the link to that is down below in
the description too thank you so much
for watching thank you so much for
coming on
and until next time until next time come
on
and then for thumbnail i'm just going to
pull a picture of it no we can't talk
we're going to
just turn off and on save we got to save
for the
there we go thank you i hit the nail on
the head
yeah i was right yeah we had a talk
earlier today about like why you don't
post much
and i was like i'm so comfortable you
just like you just are enjoying life
yeah yeah that's so cool dude i'm so
envious of
we gotta talk about your free time oh
yeah that's what we're gonna talk about
all right cool
all right whoa
this weird angle right here because it's
like the table yeah
all right all right i'll just do that
cool we're good yeah
go all right